hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter ten of Aristotle's categories
he distinguishes four different types of
opposition for ways in which things
terms can be opposed to each other and
the third type that he talks about is
what gets translated as positives and
privet is that we have to do a little
bit of talking about these greek terms
because it's not a very easy translation
perhaps primitive is a little bit closer
to what we have in mind then positive
but they are opposed in that way the
primitive is the privet 'iv it is the
absence the you know or in some cases
perhaps corruption or lack of what what
ordinarily would be there but we'll get
to that in a moment
let's talk about these two terms you
notice that the Greek term that
Aristotle is using here is hexes this
comes from the word to have in in Greek
and so if you think about something that
is a possession something that you have
for a long time you're on the right
track and we talk not only about having
things like my having this piece of
track or my having this particular tie
which I've actually had for quite some
time but we talk about habits we talk
about things that have become part of
our personality of our character and we
can also talk about things in terms of
capacities that we have as well so it's
not so alien to our own way of talking
about things and so hexxus is positive
you might also think of it in terms of
possession another word that we use to
translate it quite often is habit
because many hex ace that's the plural
for it are indeed habits state is
another term that often gets used for
translating hex
in Aristotle's works now opposed to this
is still racist and that comes from the
verb to mean to be deprived of or to be
lacking something you know when we talk
about needing something that that could
also be stir ASIS so we translate that
generally as primitive or as privation
and what you have to think of there is
the fact that primitives or privations
are always what they are in relation to
that of which they are a lack or a
deprivation so if we were to think and
Aristotle doesn't use this as an example
as a matter of fact he tends to treat
justice and injustice as being a
different type of quality and a
different type of opposition to each
other as being you know actual
contraries to each other but let's say
we thought for a moment of justice in
terms of it being a habit of the person
that was developed in them over time and
we would say ought to be there in a
person then injustice can be understood
as the lack of that which ought to be
there in that person so Aristotle
doesn't use that as an example here
instead he uses things like sight and
blindness and we will see why in just a
moment but it's important to keep in
mind these translations of these these
Greek terms so Aristotle is going to
point out right from the start that both
the hexxus
and the stasis are going to be referred
to the same subject it was a very
important point the example that he uses
our sight and blindness are referred to
what to the eye
I suppose in an analogous way we might
say that sight and blindness could also
be used in talking about a camera if the
camera lens is say damaged or obscured
or the innards of the camera
such that it can no longer take in the
visual information that is coming from
you know the whatever the lens or the
front piece right but you don't talk
about sight and blindness except in a
very metaphorical way of other things
like for example we would not talk about
the piece of chalk having sight or
blindness it's not that sort of thing we
wouldn't talk about the book being
sighted or blind right or having sight
or having blindness we're lacking sight
because it's not that sort of thing you
know we might talk about a book as
having vision right or lacking vision
but there were using it in a
metaphorical sense an equivocal sense
Aristotle would say or at analogical
sense at best and we're not talking
about actual sight and blindness and we
can do the same thing for any of the
other senses that we have you know
hearing smell touch taste we can talk
about we can talk about certain
organisms as lacking sight you know
things that don't actually have eyes
like oysters presume I don't know what
senses of' presumably a sense of pain if
you injure them and some sense of touch
and perhaps odor
you know something along those lines but
we don't really we're not really talking
about an oyster being blind because an
oyster isn't the sort of thing that
would actually have sight and so they're
always referred to the same subject that
is the thing that either ought to have
that thing or not I'll give you another
example that doesn't come from Aristotle
but it actually comes from a medieval
thinker Saint Anselm of Canterbury talks
about and just reflects sort of the
prejudices of his time the fact that a
man ought to have a beard but a boy
shouldn't because it's not time for the
boy to grow the beard right and lacking
the beard there's something wrong with
the guy
funny because we see pictures of San
tanco more images of Saint Anselm
depicted without a beard that's probably
totally inaccurate right but you get the
idea there things that could be had or
could be lacking but they're lacking in
a context so this brings us to the next
important point
Aristotle clarifies for us that what do
we what do we mean when we talk about a
privation he says that what can have X
whatever X is is deprived when X should
be present when it's natural or it's
desirable for X to be present but X
could still be lacking X is absent so he
says you know what may have a faculty is
deprived of that faculty when it is
totally absent and yet should be
naturally present and present also at
that time so not what is without teeth
or sight do we therefore call toothless
or blind just things that actually
should have teeth so if you know we're
thinking about infants infant human
beings not a big deal if they're lacking
teeth because they're probably up in the
gums and they're going to pop out and go
through teething and all that sort of
stuff but if we find out at you know age
5 that there aren't any teeth
you know let's say we didn't do x-rays
of the kid or anything like that well
then there's a problem there there's a
lack of something that we think ought to
be there so he says we rather use those
terms of that which has not but should
have teeth or sight and should have
teeth or sight at that time so that's an
important point we we we don't predicate
these terms of just anything that is
lacking we predicate them of things that
really ought to have that so that ought
to make us think about what sorts of
things should he have what properties or
characteristics should have a hexxus
that when it's lacking is
rather a stir race as a privation a an
absence of what that is now
Aristotle also makes another important
clarification
when we're talking about these terms
that there we go being deprived of
something that is the verb or the state
if you want to think about it being
deprived is not strictly speaking the
exact same thing as the privation itself
one of these is predicate all of things
the other one is not credible of things
so for example we can say that a human
being is blind ie is lacking sight in
their visual apparatus whatever time it
could be the nerves could be the eye
itself but we don't say that the person
is blindness itself the privation would
be the blindness itself being blind
being deprived of sight would be the
other thing and they're not exactly the
same thing right
likewise possessing a habit as Aristotle
says use the verb a cane to have hexxus
too heavy having literally is not the
same thing as the habit itself so to be
cited to have sight is not the same
thing as to be site or site itself and
we don't want to mix those those things
up sometimes it's not such an issue with
blindness and sight but it could be an
issue with other types of heck face and
stood race so he goes on and and he says
that there we go
yeah this may be noted that it to be
blind could be rightly considered the
same thing with blindness then we would
predicate both without doubt of
identical things but this is never the
case so he entertains the possibility
that it could be the case but and then
he says it's not now there is an
important connection though between
these so privation is opposed to habit
right they're opposites of each other
and he says so are possessing a faculty
or should be pointing here possessing a
hexxus and being deprived of it those
are opposites he says in the same way he
says we have the same type of antithesis
of being set in opposite areas from each
other so this is a very important type
of opposition it happens between things
that are indeed qualities and we want to
be careful to distinguish this from
other types of opposition's so as not to
fall into them and we also want to be
careful to maintain these distinctions
that Aristotle is giving us